so why do cue and gaining really hate
each other and are we going to find out
the truth behind it from picard series
2.
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv movie
channel
[Music]
so i recently watched a video on another
channel and it basically argued that
gainan gained her powers from her
experience with the nexus when she was
transported and ripped from the nexus by
the enterprise b
she somehow gained her ability to know
and to sense when time and things have
changed so when the enterprise c came
through that rift and time change
tassier appeared etcetera dying and
sensed it
it's also maybe why she senses q
and q's presence in this season two
episode q who but
it actually made a couple of really
interesting points and a couple of
points in that video that i just
completely disagree with
one
in that episode queue
q appears in 10 forward with picard
moments before tenfold was full of
people and he clicked them and they all
disappeared
but gainan was behind the bar she didn't
disappear so does that mean she is
somehow immune to q's powers
hold that thought we're going to come
back to it
also in that exchange between queue and
gainan he says that the last time he saw
gainan the imp as he calls her was two
centuries before
so q
and guy gaining dislike each other for
something that happened two centuries
before this incident in cuhu so i'm
going to point out that happened in
2365.
now
the nexus incident happened a little
under a century before that so whatever
happened between queue and gaining
actually happened at least 100 years
before the nexus event and 100 years
before now this is important the borg's
invasion of the allurian home world so
to understand why q and guinean hate
each other i think we have to look at
elorian's powers and we have to have a
look at what we know about q
so the loreans powers
they seem to be a little vague and a
little fuzzy but we have to try to read
between the lines a little bit for one
that incidentally where guidance behind
the bar and seems to be immune to q's
powers
is one part
another thing is when time has changed
and time and the whole universe has
changed she doesn't seem to be
completely
understand what has happened but she
knows something has happened she knows
it isn't right she knew that tasha yar
was supposed to be dead and was not
supposed to be there
but she seemed a little fuzzy on the
details it was like she was sort of just
woken up from a dream she could remember
it but it was vague we also then have to
look at the incident between the game
queue and gain in our tent forward in
the episode cue who gainan approaches q
ready to almost attack or at very least
defend herself again maybe that is
because she has the ability to be immune
to q's powers
now
if we think about what we know about q
in that instance that he is a bit of a
trickster that he likes playing games
with other races look at everything he
did testing and trying to get us to
prove ourselves in the entire exchange
in between tng and voyager
i have to wonder how would q feel about
a species of valorians that would
potentially immune to those powers
now the other thing we know about the
illurians is that they've traveled
amongst the stars a long time before we
did we see episode with gaining on earth
hundreds of years before we even
developed space travel
they were a species known as the
listeners that traveled amongst the
stars to learn about other species this
would suggest they were technologically
very advanced and even far more advanced
than we were
so is it possible that the queue did
take an interest in the eloreans like he
took interest in humans and the
federation later
maybe john de lancie's cue and maybe
other queue of this continuum had
interactions with the elonians maybe
they tested them in a similar way that
they tested us
and what frustrated them by the way the
eloreans were able to resist the q's
abilities or even be immune to them
perhaps they did what they did to us
and a cue clicked his fingers
and introduced the illurians to the borg
this is maybe why just as q is clicks
his fingers and shoots the enterprise
across the galaxy to have this first
confrontation with the borg the guy then
shouts out no stop cue don't
maybe that's because she knows exactly
what q was about to do because he'd done
it before he'd done it to her species
now humanity survived their first
encounter with the borg which i actually
generally believe was a test by the
continuum to see the to test the
resilience basically the federation
but we survived by the skin of our teeth
and we survived in lots of ways by luck
but that really kick-started a massive
technological advancement definitely in
weapons and other technology for the
federation but it also changed our
entire culture and the way we perceived
ourselves as explorers the federation
was completely and utterly changed
following its incident with the borg and
the battle of wall 359
now perhaps the illoriens weren't as
lucky as we were when they first
encountered the borg and obviously they
weren't now there is another reason why
i suspect that this could be the case
the illurian home world cannot be too
far away from the federation the
refugees came to the federation for
protection i met kirk on the enterprise
b
the home world can't have been in the
delta quadrant where we know the borg
come from so they must have been much
closer to
the alpha quadrant somewhere within the
alpha quadrant now if that's the case
why did the borg attack them the way
they did maybe it was because q did
exactly what they did to us and the borg
became interested in hillary's species
this this makes me actually think about
another point as well that the q are
actually quite afraid of the borg in the
episode q squared where we see q junior
q grabs hold of his son and throws him
down to the captain's chair says if the
continue have told you once we've told
you a thousand times don't antagonize
the borg
maybe that is because the borg even
though at the moment are something the q
tend to play with
they understand that their borg could
one day become as powerful as they are
and that is a massive threat to the
continuum
if that is the case
why would they introduce a species like
the eloreans to the borg a species that
has the innate abilities to maybe be
immune to q's powers
because that power and that ability
would be assimilated into the borg so
that is the one downside of my argument
now will we in picard series 2 get any
answers to these questions of the
relationship between guyan and picard
and the queue
this is a golden opportunity for those
questions to be answered
but in all honesty
it's not going to happen
there i actually don't think we're going
to see a lot more of gaining in the
actual series than we already have done
in the advert i think she'll only be in
it for maybe five maybe 10 minutes at
most
i think they will continue this strange
and um mysterious character the kind and
is and not answer anything not because
they're particularly clever writers or
because they want to continue that
mystery for some reason but because
they're lazy writers and they can't be
bothered to think of a good answer there
is also that opportunity for the
question of why is q so interested in
humanity to be answered and again from
what we see from the advocate i suspect
we're not going to get answers to that
either
i think next is going to be far more
likely again that when the queue leaves
we don't have any answers for why he's
interested in humanity and actually
probably more questions we have another
golden opportunity in this season of
picard though for the queue to appear
and go el capitan
why are you an android
click his fingers and make picard a
human again he could also then click his
fingers again
and erase that from our consciousness so
we can pretend that that last episode of
series one never happened so guys what
do you think now i have to say the
theory about guyan gaining her abilities
after being ripped from the nexus was
actually put forward by ronald d moore
who actually wrote the film the script
for generations so he should know right
and but does his explanation for that
make any sense please get in the
comments and you tell me but also what
do you think about my theory about why q
and geinan hate each other is it
possible that the queue actually did
destroy
via the borg the elorean home world
and what do you think picard series 2 is
going to tell us about this relationship
are we going to learn anything new are
we just going to get more questions
and more disappointments from the picard
series
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out also
you become a member of the channel and
become a fully fledged side tracker hit
that join button please as always guys
stay safe and i will see you next time
[Music]